qu'est ce que vous avez fait vous ce
week end alors moi j'ai fait beaucoup de
bricolage
oui j'ai acheté des vis des clous des
perceuses des tronçonneuses
apparemment elle sera avec deux mecs en
ce moment de placer necker voilà
j'habite dans un appartement un petit
peu vide dont il est temps que je la
mets ça fait un an que vous avez
bricoler alors vous savez bricoler ou
pas j'ai appris j'ai c'est vrai qu'il
fallait une pince alors est ce que vous
pourriez par exemple poser un cadre sur
un mur bien sûr c'est vrai j'adore
ramenez-moi amenez moi alors le cas vous
avez pris de photos de moi même qu'ils
sont cons non mais ça le mec qui va pas
du tout alors soit on a une perceuse on
a tous alors vous me cassez vous le
mettez bien nos milieux là d'accord on
va là vraiment c'est la corée du nord
l'émission hier c'est par médéric le mur
et tu as même pas quand vous étiez père
tenait le meur sir elton mur je suis pas
là non mais attendez
elle va le faire pendant qu'on fait le
tour de table ah oui vous pensez
vraiment que vous pouvez le faire
bah si j'ai le bon matos voilà pas très
bien mais moi j'avais une comme elle
était là elle était mieux la mienne oui
mais ba ba les sénateurs j'allais
rentrer chez vous allez chercher votre
je viendrai d'accord non mais c'est bon
vous mettez ça va ça va kiev qui
personne derrière ça c'est plat copains
du plat kwassa battant des ailes ça va
calmer toi moi qui habite année mais
attendez vous savez quoi et je vous le
dis allez vous mettre là pendant la pub
vous allez le maître vous allez avoir
sept minutes jolie pour mettre le cadre
d'accord on va filmer quoi sans problème
sans problème bien sûr je mangeais droit
mais for africa bull tout de suite on a
dit pas tout de suite c'est pas une
parisien 10e mais c'est le 10e trou
c'est une vicieuse c'est ce qu'elle ait
pas de connaissances vous m'avez donnée
mobile et bientôt mais non parce qu'il
faut il faut il faut il faut alors vous
allez chercher la mèche tout ça pour
l'instant
vous allez là-bas et intel mais daccords
avc moi elle le mènera pendant la pub
mais elle a la balle elle a mis deux
coups elle est mon père aussi avoir un
menuisier il fait pas toute une histoire
c'était le clou du spectacle qu'est-ce
qui a été le clou du spectacle alors
partout
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon et le clou du spectacle mon
vieux tu dois te dire ça tu es
complètement marteau
[Applaudissements]
moi je les classe non qu'est ce que t'en
fous tu sors pas en reste là reste là
moi je suis inquiète pas et ça vaut pas
un clou
[Applaudissements]
acker longueur